Boris Johnson arriving to present a
manifesto he says will unite the country
it sounds like he's got some work to do
but he's got plenty of backers to his
debt brexit dom pledge sealing the deal
for many voters puts in his name to
another brexit promise will he keep it
this time around and here here it is a
slim manifesto short on policy big on
brexit rhetoric with a deal that is
precooked ready to go get rex it done
and we can restore confidence and
certainty to business under families get
brexit done and we'll see a pent up
tidal wave of investment into this
country get rex it done and we can focus
our hearts and our minds on the
priorities of the british people
targeted but limited spending on those
priorities the police nurses hospitals
schools in this manifesto we pledged
fifty thousand more nurses and their
bursaries and 15 million more GP surgery
appointments and today we make this
guarantee to the british people that we
will tackle crime with twenty thousand
more police officers and tougher
sentencing and that we will sort out our
immigration system with a points-based
australian style system but keeping the
cost down we can all these things
without raising our income tax v80 or
national insurance contributions a
frugal option unlike the opposition
korban onyx macdonald omics needs higher
taxes for everybody in this country two
thousand four hundred pounds extra our
gym voters to stick with what they know
and reject the alternative you want to
wake up on friday the 13th of december
and find a nightmare on Downing Street a
a Corbin a Corbin sturgeon coalition of
chaos I say let's go carbon neutral by
2050 and Corbyn neutral by Christmas
let's go these promises worth more than
the ones that came before you promised
in income tax cut for higher earners now
dropped from the manifesto you always
also promised do or die to leave the EU
October the 31st when you didn't have
the majority in parliament deliver on
that promise
voters laughed at you when you said that
truth in politics is important do you
understand why many people simply don't
trust you yes it's true that we are not
prioritizing tax cuts for the high
earners at the moment we are looking of
course at the moment to to do what we
can to help people with the cost of
living the brexit delay not his fault
see what happened if you remember was
that Parliament decided to give a first
approval to that withdrawal agreement
which everybody said was impossible and
they then senselessly voted to extend
yet again dodging the trust question is
it his Achilles heel why do you think is
that people laugh at Boris Johnson when
he talks about truth and being him truth
being important and they think it's a
joke they don't think he's trustworthy
well if you want to see people
delivering on their commitments look at
what he said on the steps of Downing
Street and what he's delivered already
he said he hasn't delivered flags as he
he said he'd get a new day that was his
main face he said he'd get a new deal on
brexit and he has a any wait sometimes a
record-high one in three children living
in poverty that's a conservative record
for the past decade when Astrid people
vote for you again as you've heard from
their Prime Minister that when we get
brexit done it gives us more scope to
focus on these things the people's
priorities Boris Johnson has one big
message in this election that's to get
brexit done and he doesn't really want
to detract from that so this is a rather
slim line manifesto full of lots of
pictures the conservative offer on
public services is pretty modest when
compared with Labour's but Boris Johnson
gamble in that this is a brexit election
and voters will see it that way to
Jeremy Corbyn campaigning in thorak
trying to get it back onto his ground in
Telford in the Midlands the area where I
grew up the Conservative Party is
launching its manifesto a manifesto paid
for by billionaires written for
billionaires and will be delivered for
billionaires but the problem is the rest
of us will have to pay for it and so
when you've got a Conservative Party
that has been in coalition government of
government on its own for 10 years made
the political choice in 2010 of
austerity on the people of this country
it's not them who pay for it labour
wanted this to be the austerity election
but this man's brexit message still
front and center stage he doesn't need
to win over new voters with this
manifesto all he needs to do is hold on
to his vote leave support convincingly
ahead in the polls if it stays this way
he's heading for a majority Beth Rigby
Sky News Telford